so if you've noticed that some episodes
and scenes from your favorite shows have
kind of been disappearing lately you're
not losing your mind it's really
happening there's a great episode of
friends that features a lesbian wedding
it was first aired as the 11th episode
of season two meaning it aired in 1996
so if you're up on your history you know
that it was actually pretty
groundbreaking it was the first time a
lesbian wedding had been shown on the
air in fact in the episode Ross's ex
Carol marries her fiance Susan and Not
only was it important to the storyline
of the show it was culturally important
too however not everyone saw this scene
as inspiring for starters it was banned
in several countries around the world
not super surprising considering how
many places there still are where it's
illegal to be gay but it was also banned
in certain areas of the US like parts of
Texas and Ohio and of course for the
rest of the country this scene aired and
shock the world was still there the next
day